okay so it's you you feeling sleepy
tired or are you up for another another
game we have one more challenge before
we end the stream if you're feeling down
yeah okay let's do it
let's do it alright let's see if your
sorrow is still here it's but we're
gonna do it like a five minute the game
now okay yeah yeah okay alright yeah
three is just in three I'm just gonna
ruin your game by pre moving okay let's
play it for all right
no but it's it's anyway still it's like
you know it's like twice what I was told
telling you night of three now it's not
that I'm not even moving the mouse it's
just I also have to see what I'm doing
see sorry let's say yeah it's a weird d4
yeah but it's only because you have a
secret 8c takes yeah yeah I guess it's
only because you have a secret identity
well I mean depends here because I mean
you think it's that if I would play with
my handle I would yeah much faster yeah
at least
yeah so e5 okay
okay this is interesting so let's say
nice history all right
already hard to say what is this so
let's go Bishop b5 let's have some fun
Bishop b5 is having some fun all right
kind of kind of some okay what else here
mm-hmm
let's go oh oh my god
I have to work on my chest Bishop e3
let's go all right
[Music]
that's actually maybe a good move h3
let's say alright Queen f3 all right I
guess I mean I wouldn't go ga-ga would
be a towels mafia yeah we're talking
about it and then f/4g for ya go
something but do you remember did she
take steps three against but we nee you
know what what was it Carolyn or
something when he talked G takes us me
caro-kann I think G for now G for yeah
okay it's not whiskey or anything it's
tea by the way because everybody is
asking me like taking this year is it
because I mean for some I think I did
some life with Kuryakin or something we
should take c6 okay
and they were asking if it's something
else than tea but it's not
I don't know fortunately or
unfortunately what kind of tea just
black sea nothing special yeah okay
watch what should we do now
let's go can we have some fun h4 maybe
okay
hmmm this is already very very intense
it's hard to say what's going on to be
honest
at least a 30 yeah the weirder Sicilian
it's a very very position I don't know
what's going on that's very good to hear
yeah I don't I don't really know what's
going on to be honest yeah probably I
didn't do
h5 let's say okay okay what's this
no it's interesting okay
yeah it's interesting what's going on
yeah glad I'm not playing this game okay
let's try some h6h six okay in the style
of alpha zero kind of it is bad alpha
zero I would say in the style of very
bad alpha zero in the style of Rahab oh
oh oh yeah oh yeah that sounds more to
the point okay let's go Castle
short-short castles alright
what do I say there thanks for the
contribution man okay let's go Luke from
rental meant let me see
Luke a ec1 all right
let's sacrifice something or someone
so let's go night it'll all right I see
what you are doing very very good not
sure actually but it's so good mm-hmm
it's interesting
okay let's go some okay he's playing
strong Ashley so what can I say let's go
some Queen - G - let's see what what's
he's up for ya okay he's playing very
strong in jail I like his chest actually
it's playing very good
it's my fellow Kings Indian grave yeah
he is he really loves the Kings Indian
f4 alright
okay let's go um say okay let's say King
H - okay yeah
e takes f6 okay yeah okay let's go what
do we go here
night-night
- Ji Won
oh we're bad on time again as usual
yeah that's the usual sing night of 395
if takes e5 this should take C 1 this
should be 61 oh yeah
Bishop b3 Queen f1 o
queen d1 not playing a good game simply
it's just fire
[Music]
kingi three all right for this is super
super intense queen f1
oh he gave us some time Oh Queenie - he
gave us 30 seconds
very very gentlemanly yeah she's a
gentlemanly ace real moment yes real
let's say
[Music]
Quinn f3
that was very bold with the queen bee
three
no I think it's okay cherrylle wild Wow
he's playing really strong I mean okay
what is this king h4 let's say and we do
the scales go pitch for seems like a
plan
like kabedon mmm I like it I like
Badlands yeah especially in quarantine
just when you have Badlands Queen let's
say if six yeah he's great
bravo Bravo Bravo G takes f five King to
whatever
Jesus ryoga's G to
no just g3 yeah when software the cool
let's be fair that he played a great
game okay we offer a draw I know he
wants the oh she was licking just three
come on we're old guys here to playing
one game oh yeah oh yeah yeah but we
really barely saved this yeah thank you
sorry for the game but it was a great
one especially this Quinby 3q industry
and 94-95 stuff yeah it was I thought he
he couldn't go for the four that you to
to abandon the f6 square but but no but
he gave us 15 seconds he gave us 15
seconds no 30 30
ah he gave us 30 seconds yeah 15 and
then 15 more yeah in that position it's
like donation yeah a big one they tipped
us see I should start playing her from
my account to try to be just earth in a
matter definitely I think okay we will
do something about that thank you so
much for the for the stream thank you it
was really pleasure yeah and thanks for
joining
hope to hope to have you over for some
more chess and fun some sometimes yeah I
will also have all this banter blade
sessions and so on so everybody's
welcome to come there yeah talking and
playing on this before the Magnus
tournament or after depends where the
schedule puts me there yeah okay thank
you so much for the stream thank you
okay later man yeah